when Martin Schmidt was made coach at
mines just over a year ago the club were
a point of the relegation zone now
they're all sins are running for a
Champions League spot Schmidt Hayes from
Switzerland in his younger years he
played for his hometown club natus when
he wasn't busy climbing mountains
plummeting down them as an extreme skier
attuning race cars in his own workshop
he also finds a time set of a closing
firm Martin Schmidt men who seen plenty
of action either a forum is mystic oh he
has August every experience matters oh
because whether I was an employee
working as part of a group maybe it's
roughly a lot as a manager in charge of
a company and not whether i was working
along commercial lines are as a mechanic
working with race car engines
fine-tuning optimal trying to extract
every last bit of potential it's a kind
of us are also kidson ozan making a car
another ten kilos lighter we're getting
three or four more horsepower out of the
engines albeit anomaly and working at
the limit is exactly what i'm doing here
professionally aeon terrific a
bundesliga spill on the players who are
already at a very high level but my job
is to find out where I can still improve
things does look better get what a smart
in Schmidt stand for yeah I talk essence
model of the essence [ __ ] seeker
like first I believe one hundred percent
in passion and emotions Oh plus we
Okinawa are absolutely indispensable
like a motor racing back in the day
media called me a full throttle
performer perhaps mainland my playing
days in the Swiss second division the
kind of guy who'd run up and down the
pitch the whole game done about chief
Otto I was the same as a skier to farm
beam what if desert and what I have my
car tuning workshop I wanted customers
to get a really souped-up car
something that could stand out with bong
in the field involving votes is he up
going to go by bus with the clothing for
him later not which I still run with my
sisters the point wasn't just about
outfitting a company gets manifested
food it was also about the right image
and their group performance oh it's
group of treat an open to open above it
whether you're in a construction firm
ball club or a Racing crew and perform
as a team act like a team and look like
if you want to do lunch a little better
and as soon as you have pragmatism and
technique and pace all together temple
and you can underpin that with all the
passion and emotions and the product you
end up with is many times greater I'm
being constant construct an asset's
product us to rouse wholesome so Viva
Las Cruces Schmidt credo is you play
like you train that says the coach is
minus only hope for pulling off
fairytale upsets against bigger clubs
man Chavan's waffle making the mute
somebody unless there's some time talk
of fairy tales when we're the underdogs
and beat a big team the sky defies
belief in financial terms siding playing
against teams who have a 100 million
euro budget while we only have 25
million giving the unknown penalty and
if you look at the table for a few weeks
now we've been between 6th and 8th what
we should plot second octant on so room
the club does indicate think that's a
good place for us does him again the
husband's got I know it'll be a really
hard fight harder London havoc on string
of the compass well that's right for us
being first behind the big teams it's
like winning the league only myself
eating a lot of other sides want to be
in that spot than gruel since assigned
us it's a kind of unofficial title
gigantic attempt we don't own them ding
camper on talkin